now Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu says that his military
campaign is showing results and will
continue for as long as
necessary in the past few days dozens of
Hamas terrorists have surrendered to our
forces they are laying down their
weapons and turning themselves in to a
heroic soldiers this will take time the
war is still ongoing but it is the
beginning of the end for Hamas I say to
the Hamas terrorists it's over don't die
for sin surrender
now let's go to Alan Fischer who is an
occupied EAS tourism Alan prime minister
Netanyahu once again reiterating his
commitment to the war in Gaza what else
has he been
saying well I can tell you that just in
the last couple of hours the Israeli
Army has confirmed that four people were
killed in fighting overnight that brings
the number of Israeli soldiers that have
been killed since the start of the war
to 101 three of them were killed in the
fighting in can yunas and we know that
there has been heavy fighting because
Benjamin Netanyahu told us in and around
can yunas and jabalia refugee camp
that's in the northern part of Gaza
there's also been intense fighting in
the South now Benjamin Netanyahu is
aware of the international condemnation
that has come particularly from the
United Nations where all but one of the
15 members uh sorry all but two of the
15 members voted for a ceasefire Britain
of course abstained the United States
voted against
but he's also boyed by the fact that
just in the last couple of days he's
received $16 Million worth of ammunition
to help fuel the war now people are
saying that behind the scenes the United
States is putting pressure on Israel but
there's nothing overt about what the
United States are saying they're very
much in lock step and Benjamin Netanyahu
is encouraged by that level of support
from his closest Ally certainly they've
been talking about the possibility of
this war extending ending for another
two months at least Benjamin Netanyahu
says they've defined goals the release
of the captives the destruction of Hamas
and also what he describes as the
deradicalization of Gaza and they will
continue to work towards those goals but
by calling for Hamas to surrender he's
maybe hoping slightly that he can
perhaps truncate this war maybe bring it
to a close sooner rather than later
because as I say he's aware of the huge
International outrage of the growing
number of civilians that are being
killed as Israel prosecutes this war by
land a and
sea and Allan's senior Israeli officials
have also wrapped up another late night
meeting uh do we know what's come out of
those
talks yeah couple of big meetings in
Jerusalem on Sunday uh one of the
meetings was of the socioeconomic
cabinet now they obviously discussing
the economic situation in Israel at the
moment because the economy has taken a
massive hit because of the war they were
discussing whether or not to transfer
taxes that have been gathered from
Palestinian workers to the Palestinian
Authority so that they can pay those
workers uh particularly those in the
security services so that they can
continue to feed their family the other
question is about those who hold passes
to allow them to work in Israel no one
has worked in Israel from the West Bank
or Gaza for the last three months belel
smut chose the Finance Minister Dead Set
against both of those things he's one of
the ultra nationalists in the Israeli
cabinet he doesn't want to see that
happen he thinks that that's a huge
security risk Benjamin Netanyahu we're
told is in favor of both those measures
but the
socioeconomic cabinet couldn't make a
decision they deferred it to the
security cabinet to make a final
decision and the security cabinet has
decided not to make a decision at all so
for the time being all those Palestinian
workers who rely on their jobs in Israel
they won't be allowed to travel they're
seen as a security risk and there'll be
no transfer of funds to the Palestinian
Authority for the moment either both of
those issues well they're not going to
make a decision on them right now Alan
Fischer there for us in occupied East
Jerusalem